All right, I'm in my Cloud Code and it
says listening for channel messages from
the plugin iMessage. And on my phone
right here, I've got iMessage pulled up
and I'm going to shoot off this text
that says, "Scrape the YouTube comments
from my recent video and give me a
breakdown." And what you'll see right
here on my terminal is that we have
iMessage and it says, "Scrape the
YouTube comments blah blah blah." So,
this is the exact text that I just sent
off. And now, Cloud Code is acting as if
I just typed this message right here
locally on my machine. So, it's able to
use all of the skills that I've got in
here. It's able to look through all of
these different folders and files. It's
able to use my API keys and things like
that. And we're able to on our terminal
watch all of this happening. And as you
can see what it did is it used my
YouTube analyzer skill in order to
achieve this for us.
So, that skill finished up and it sent
the reply back to myself in iMessage.
You can see that it was able to scrape
511 comments across six recent videos
with some biggest themes and some top
video requests. And so, right here in my
iMessage, you can see here it is. We
have the top themes, feature access
frustration, token usage limit anxiety,
and then pivot backlash, open cloud
versus Cloud Code, all of this kind of
stuff. We have strongest video requests
like Manas AI, Cloud Code plus APIs,
blah blah blah. And then we have
standout comments. It also ends the
message with sent by Claude, which is
pretty nice. But, what you will notice
is that because I'm texting myself in
iMessage, it's basically going to
duplicate every single one of my
messages, whether Claude sent it or
whether I sent it. There are obviously
some fixes here. So, the purpose of this
video is to show you guys how this
works, how to set it up, and what you
need to know. So, let's get into it. All
right, so Cloud Code released channels,
which you probably already knew about.
This came out about a week ago, but this
basically allowed you to start talking
to your Cloud Code session through
select MCPs. And this started with
Telegram and Discord. But, it seemed
like it was just today that they
announced that iMessage is now also
available as a channel, which is super
exciting. So, just to start off real
quick, what is a channel? Basically,
it's like giving Cloud Code a phone
number. It basically allows us to talk
to Cloud Code through some sort of
third-party app like Telegram, Discord,
or iMessage, and it basically sends that
through like a tunnel or, you know, a
bridge or a channel, and it can send and
reply. So, as you saw in the demo, it
basically just takes my message from
iMessage and then inserts it into the
conversation inside of Cloud Code. And
by the way, this mark, I burnt myself on
my oven the other day. Anyways, that's
cool because then, locally on your
computer, Cloud Code acts as if you were
sitting there talking to it. So, we're
getting more and more to the place where
you're able to use your sessions as you
want wherever you are. Now, one of the
biggest downsides to this feature right
now is that if that session closes out,
so if I go back into my VS Code and I
basically go control C, see? Now, if I
text in my iMessage, nothing would
happen. It would not actually access
Cloud Code. And so, that can be
frustrating if, you know, you want to be
gone for a couple days and you're
worried about your laptop turning off or
an update restarting or whatever it is.
You would have to go back locally, open
up a new session, and then you could use
that channel again.
There are obviously some fixes here, you
could host your Cloud Code on a VPS and
keep it running all the time with
something like a tmux. But, one of the
catches here with the iMessage channel
is that it's iMessage, meaning wherever
you're running Cloud Code has to be on
Mac OS. So, that is why you can probably
tell today I am on my laptop, which is a
MacBook. The good news though is that
there are some ways that you can have
like sort of a Mac OS VPS. And if you
wanted to host Cloud Code there or on a
Mac Mini, then you'd be all set and you
could use this channel 24/7. Now, the
coolest part about this is it might seem
like you need to know how to set up like
some sort of weird bridge or a tunnel,
but it actually couldn't be simpler. You
basically just run a few commands, run
the plugin, and you're all set. So, let
me talk about how this works and maybe a
few things that you might run into as
far as issues. So, as we know, a channel
is an MCP server that pushes events into
your running Cloud Code session so that
Claude can react to things that happen
while you're not at the terminal, which
is great. I'm not going to dive into all
the technical details right here, but if
you want to go to the documentation,
just go to cloudcode.docs and then
search for channels or push events into
a running session with channels. So, as
we know, we have three supported
channels right now and it does require
you to install bun. So, I didn't know
what that was before looking at all this
stuff. All you have to do is, you know,
take this link up here, give it to Cloud
Code and say, "Hey, I want to set up a
channel for Discord or for iMessage.
Read this documentation and then help me
set up everything." And it will
basically install everything that you
need. So, we've got different steps here
for Telegram, Discord, and iMessage, but
they basically follow the same pattern
of making sure you have the right
access, installing the plugin, and then
launching Claude with that channel
enabled. So, the first thing you're
going to want to do is you're going to
want to grant full disk access on your
local Mac settings. So, basically what
that means is you're going to open up
your settings, you're going to go to
privacy and security, you're going to go
to full disk access, and then add
whatever you need as far as where you're
using Cloud Code. So, this does have to
be used in the terminal, but the good
news is you can use this in Visual
Studio Code like I've shown in basically
all my other YouTube videos. So, all I
had to do was enable full disk access
for Visual Studio Code. Now, the next
thing you're going to have to do is
you're going to have to install the
plugin, which once again could not be
simpler. You're just going to copy this
command right here. You're going to go
into your Cloud Code and for here I'm
just going to launch a default version
of Cloud Code, copy in that plugin, and
then when I send it off, it will
basically give you the option to install
it. You can see right here, I've already
installed this globally. And if I go to
/plugin, I could basically see all these
plugins. And you can even see here, if I
searched for the Discord one, I could
install the Discord one right there. And
if I went to Telegram, I could grab the
Telegram one right there. But, if I go
over to the ones that I've actually
already installed, you could see right
here I have the iMessage plugin, which
is already connected and enabled. Now,
once you've done that, all you have to
do is copy this next command, which
launches a fresh session of Claude, but
it does it in this channel mode. So, if
I exit out of this Cloud Code and I
paste in that way where I'm running
Cloud Code like this, it basically says
right away listening for channel
messages at iMessage. So, then what I
could do is I could open up my iMessage,
I could just say, "Hey, can you hear
me?" And when I shoot that off, we
should see that in just a second pop up
right here in our Cloud Code session.
And here's a quick example. I didn't
launch this one in bypass permissions,
so it says, "Hey, I need to do this. Do
you want to let me proceed?" And here is
where I would in my local session say
yes or no. But, it does tell us right
here that we could reply on our
iMessage, so I can go yes, m w u p y.
And if I shoot that off, then let's see
if Claude's able to get that and
actually take action. There we go. So,
that's how you're able to approve things
from your phone so you're not completely
blocked off in case you forgot about
some sort of permission. And you can
also see here that Cloud Code is able to
send emojis, which is cool. So, right
now I'm texting myself on iMessage and
that's basically how this thing works.
If you want to be able to text yourself
from a different number or have other
people be able to text your Cloud Code,
then all you have to do is allow
different numbers to. But, the very
first time when you text yourself after
this channel set up, it may pop up right
here and say like, "Hey, I'm getting a
text from this number. Is this you?
Should I allow it? Blah blah blah." And
that's where you just say yes. But, if
you wanted to allow other members to be
able to text your Cloud Code, then all
you have to do is /iMessage access
allow, and then you can either do a
phone number or you could also do an
Apple ID. And then, that Apple ID or
that phone number could also text your
Cloud Code session. So, if you really
wanted to get rid of these double texts,
then you would just want to text this
number. So, right here is, you know, my
Nate Herc um Apple ID, and I would just
want to text that number or that Apple
ID from a different account or from a
different number. And then I could just
have like basically a one-way
conversation that feels more like a
human or, you know, an AI agent. Now,
Pro and Max users, that's basically all
you have to do is install the plugin and
then run Cloud Code in that way. But,
for enterprise users or if you're on a
team plan, then you're going to have to
make sure the admin allows channel use
because by default it will be turned
off. But, all of the plans should be
able to use this once everything's
configured correctly. So, if that is
you, you would basically just go to your
admin settings, Cloud Code, and then
channels. So, here I am in my
organization settings. You can see that
I've got a lot of options here that I
can turn on like fast mode, remote
control. A lot of these are because
they're in research preview. Right here
at the bottom we have channels and this
is where we could actually enable that.
And one final thing that I wanted to
cover, which I think is a very valid
question, is the difference because
there's lots of ways now that we can
control our local sessions from our
phone or from, you know, the go. And we
have dispatch, we have channels, and we
have remote control. So, I basically
came to the docs and I said, "Hey,
what's the difference?" And here's what
it pulled. Dispatch is message a task
from your mobile app. Claude runs on
your machine. It's best for delegating
work while you're away with minimal
setup.
Channels means you push events from chat
apps like Telegram, Discord, iMessage,
or your own servers into a running
session, which is best for reacting to
external events like CI failures or chat
messages. And remote control, drive a
running session from claude.ai/code or
the mobile app, which is best for
steering in-progress work from another
device. And so, that still might to you
sound like it's all basically the same
thing. The key difference here is the
trigger. Dispatch is message-based,
channels are event-based, and remote
control is for direct control of an
active session. So, hopefully that
should clear things up a little bit.
They're all very different, they're all
kind of similar, but they're all
steering us in the direction of
Anthropic wanting us to be able to use
Cloud Code from anywhere, which I think
is obviously great. And I know that this
is an iMessage plugin or channel, but
even if you're doing your green SMSs, if
they're being sent to that number, then
Cloud Code should also be able to read
those and respond to those as well. So,
that is going to do it for this video.
If you enjoyed it and learned something
new, please give it a like. It helps me
out a ton. And as always, I appreciate
you guys made it to the end of the
video. I'll see you on the next one.
Thanks, everyone.